Alright. So now we know how to parseJSON data. How do we actually retrieve that
from our server? This is where XMLHttPRequest come in. An XMLHttpRequest allows
our Javascript code running in a browser to fire a request off to our server to
a specific URL. We can also specify a function call once the server responds to
our request. Now, there are a few steps to this. First, we need to create a new
XMLHttpRequest object, and we do this using the new keyword, followed by
XMLHttpRequest with the parentheses. Now, note that case is sensitive here.
Next, we need to call the XMLHttpRequest open method. First, we need to specify
the HTTP method to use. In our cases, we're pretty much always going to want to
use GET. Second, we specify the URL to call out to. For example, if we were
requesting a JSON file, we would specify the file name that we were interested
in. Finally, we specify a Boolean value that is set to true if we want the call
to be asynchronous. We pretty much always want the call to be asynchronous.
Next, we specify the onload parameter, which is a function that we define that
gets called once the server responds to our request. Finally, we need to call
the xhr.send method. This will actually kick-off the request. Note that we need
to do all of these things first, before we can call send. Otherwise, the request
might hit the server and respond before we can specify our onload function. And
if that happens, we won't actually know what to do with the response yet.